Oh
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to 13 o'clock
podcast this is episode 25 boid episodes
of rolling by Arthur yeah now we want
that every week don't we really not we
can't believe how many episodes we have
seems like a week you know comes up
quick yeah yeah Donegan oh I'm going by
fast I like laughs now when I work yeah
okay so what we want to do first like we
usually do give a shout-out to the
project Entertainment Network on which
our audio version of the podcast is
hosted they have a patreon page still if
you want to go on over there and give
them a buck or two that'd be really rad
there's a bunch of other podcasts on
there that are super awesome and you
know we run commercial form sometimes
they're all really cool you're sure
you'll find something you like on there
if you like this show yeah I have
addendum are still number four out of
about 13 shows yeah I think more shows
going to get added soon yeah there is
another show being out of next month I
believe so if you like to show where
this with your friends yes only a
spoken-- things like definitely be that
appreciate it yeah and the project
Entertainment Network would appreciate
it as well
yeah some savatage ain't getting a
hundred friend request on facebook proof
birthday now yeah I don't know how that
happened
I must have reached some kind of
critical mass where I was turning up and
everyone suggested friends because at
first I thought they were all like fake
accounts but then people started messing
we said no oh I just heard your podcast
or no doesn't that I just you know that
and you got half an India trying to
friend you well yeah okay I've
experienced that before yeah but and
also since this is another kind of
paranormal II ghosty type of topic we're
doing today I also want to remind
everybody I have a new book coming out
probably be finished by the end of this
month I'm not promising anything but
it's called the unseen hands there's
going to be a great book yeah I hope
that the definitive work yeah and if you
are interested in poltergeist phenomena
then it's kind of going to be I kind of
my my goal was to make it kind of like a
one-stop shop where basically I have
summaries of well over a hundred
poltergeist type cases
I wanted like the sixth century yeah
good ones ones that were actually
witnessed by the authorities of the time
right yeah and things that were
documented that they actually had
witnesses yeah I can't prior tale yeah
number a couple I discussed a couple of
like ones that were probably hoaxes in
there too just to provide some contrast
but um and also it's going to have like
the end section is going to be like what
you know what the current like pair of
psychological Sciences on what causes
them or you know how they could be
hoaxes
various other things there's a lot of
book like this kind of on ghost
phenomena but I've never seen one on
poltergeist yeah there are problems I
think there are very few very few
they're just poltergeists eccentric
right this is going to be the newest one
probably be a very popular book I
predict it's going to be your best
seller I hope so yeah
yeah but yeah the printed ebook I'm
trying to get it out by the end of the
month
and then I'm going to do an audiobook
version two audiobook version yeah but
that will probably take much longer but
I'll let everybody know when that is up
- yeah and the audiobook is going to be
long because this is a long book as I
wouldn't surprise me at that audio book
could be thirty five forty dollars but
it's probably five hours well-written
it's gonna be more like eight hours I
like nine hours completely keep
considering how long my life is okay so
it will provide hours of entertainment
and knowledge yeah sure okay so with all
of that housekeeping out of the way
let's get to the topic today which like
I said it's kind of a ghost detecting
paranormal type of thing yeah we're
talking about the skull experience old
skull experiment now if you don't know
the skull experiment is often put forth
in the paranormal community as one of
the most compelling some of the most
compelling evidence of life after death
they usually want to say yes or
paranormal phenomena in general and I
should say - generally referred to as
the skull experiment but actually it was
a series of essentially seances yes
about 500 a series of about 500 seances
taking place over a five year period
from 1993 to 19
ninety-eight yeah and they took place in
a Pharma most of them took place in a
farmhouse in a little village called
skull in Norfolk in Norfolk in England
and which is why they're called the
skull experiment now the stated goal of
the skull experiment was to see if they
could establish communication with the
dead and basically the core group was
four mediums it was two sets of married
couples Robyn and Sandra Foy and Allen
and Diana Bennett and so that was like
the core group their spirit their
spiritualist yes and there are also a
couple other mediums and they also had
over the course of it they had many
investigators usually from the Society
for psychical research that would come
and sit in and I think on some of the
other some of the other stances they
also had like visitors and things now
the members of the Society for psychical
research that came some of them were
scientists you know they've been some of
the like you know plant biologists
engineers that type of thing and I think
what we're going to do will probably
we're just going to kind of go through
and say like what the manifestations
were that appeared at these various
seances and then maybe you know after
the break we'll kind of break down what
happened what yeah what happens and what
the results of this experiment was
radley right so basically I mean they
started this series of experiments and
according to them they have you know
they have an official website called the
school experiment calm and you can go
look at it if you want to they said that
when they first started out they didn't
really get much for the first few weeks
I think they had a seance about every
month sometimes they were more often
yeah and I would say the product kind of
like the ringmaster of this whole
experiment was wrong boy well yeah Robin
offender boy they were the one that
started it and it should be noted that
most of the experiments took place at
their house like I said their house in
school on in a base yeah when the 17th
century farmhouse and they had a they
had a big basement in the house and
that's where almost almost all of the
seances took place and were big claims
about this phenomenal yeah I'm really
weird phenomena they claimed to catch it
is pretty weird you know but we'll we'll
get to that but I'm I'm going to say so
it took a while for anything to kind of
come about yeah I think they were
messing around what about a year before
they got yeah I think it might have been
about a year they were kind of like
trying to contact people and whatnot not
actively dead it's like the offices you
know pretty much like the 19th century
spiritualism
they were basically spiritualist they
are spiritual yeah in there they're
spirits listen along the lines of you
know what you saw in them in the 1800's
in the 1900s
yeah very new agey yeah and it should be
said too I mean Robin and Sandra Foy are
you know what are called physical
mediums you know which if you know
anything about you know early know like
19th century early 20th century
spiritualism those are mediums who can
produce physical objects now back in the
day they used to do ectoplasm and that's
what was moving things and all this
other kind of stuff now these guys they
do the same kind of stuff but they say
they don't need a supply of them anymore
because now they have like some kind of
spirit energy or whatever so they don't
have to do the ectoplasm thing and that
I don't know exercisin is always kind of
fascinating because I'm like what where
did that idea come from that you had
like this kind of ghost not coming out
of your nose or out of here mouth
because that was a very common aspect of
early the early spiritual as well yeah
if you ask me all right let's just just
be a straight shooter
they needed a trick to do do a seance
so you just put an object somewhere and
then you pull that object out yeah well
in this case you could take water dust a
cheese cloth Cotton's and stuff that up
some bodily orifices pull it out pull it
out of there and I'm naming you makeup
on your day
you make up an explanation of what it is
yeah that's actual plasm oh yeah what is
ectoplasm do
exoglass does this and his neck it moves
things around and move things around so
it was just a trick they could do yeah
they're a definite photographs from the
1900 of ectoplasm how many people knows
know the husband's in bad isness yeah
yeah I think we mentioned better than
Feeny all right spiritualists no and it
says these cloth
it looks like clock it is quarter or it
looks like cotton it is cotton yeah it
usually look at that sometimes painted
with the luminous paint if you al with a
photograph in it yeah there's one
favorite picture photograph of ectoplasm
with a woman's face in the ectoplasm
it's obviously a cutout photograph away
and inside the cotton yeah yeah oh she's
manifesting yeah they probably looked a
lot better in the dark I'm just saying
yeah but uh so anyway back to the school
experiment so so they started this
series of seances now they claim that it
took about until I don't think it's
quite a year but it was in about October
1993 I think they started in February
1993 in October 1993 they said they got
their first physical manifestation and
this was a coin that i ported
quote-unquote appeared out of thin air
and landed on the table and then they
started seeing all these lights that
were kind of flickering around the room
and things like that
now over the course of the five years
that they were doing the skull
experiments there was a wide wide range
of various physical manifestations one
of the most common ones was life that
would kind of flicker around the room or
sometimes they said that they would
bounce off of tabletops and like making
noise like something hitting the tables
up yeah this is like a light would come
down out of the sky or out of it you
know there's a near the ceiling area and
hit it table yeah and then it would do
it against that and then flip through
the table
yeah underneath the table yeah and
banished things like that yeah well or
one a light would commented in one case
it touched a woman's knee and supposedly
he'll hurt me yeah that's right yeah
they were supposed to have healing
powers yeah and then they started
development called like a spirit team
and this was a team of goats on the
other side that spoke to them and taught
them things and you know if even sent
them messages you can get into that too
by the photographs yeah like I said bill
right so other than the lights
there were also a great deal of
applications you know objects appearing
out of thin air landing on the table it
was usually small items you know jewelry
that coins that jumper thing a vintage
newspaper from the 40s yes that would
actually um they thought that they had
contacted the spirit of what was a Helen
Duncan right yes that was her name she
was tried she was a medium during
wartime and she was actually tried for
witchcraft I think if they thought she
was a spy right I recall correctly
because she predicted some things she
couldn't he couldn't have known right
only the Germans were known about that
yeah that's right so yeah anyone she was
a shiny new driver was shot at before I
remember correct yeah that's right I
think we saw a documentary about that I
know that a ship had sunk and she could
have only known that as she known
somebody that was on a top-secret panel
inside the English military that relay
or possibly the Germans but I think they
tried her for witchcraft just I think
just to shut her up yeah probably about
that but if you get it shipped yeah at
some point the mediums involved in the
school experiment claimed that they had
contacted Helen Duncan and one of the
app words was a newspaper from 1944 I
believe that landed on the table in
front of them and had an article about
her being convicted yeah nobody crap now
this now but here's the weird thing
though me baby bit okay so weird think
about all that
Darth Vader voice behind that Darth
Vader but the weird thing about the
newspaper I will say is that evidently
the newspaper was analyzed and it was a
newspaper from that time period it was
authenticated it was authenticated you
know the type of printing they use the
type of paper they use it it was a
newspaper from 1944 and evidently it
wasn't yellowed like it was new like it
I don't know if it looked new really cuz
I've seen photographs of it yeah I think
it was in good condition yeah it was in
good condition it wasn't yellows like a
like a paper from 1944 would like you
think it would be so that was one of the
app words and oh well hold on oh you got
a got to mention it what the the medium
medium right I think it was it was
fourth wife right yeah under her name in
Agra she was speaking in the voice of
this medium from the nineteen forties
crying and wine and about her trial yeah
that's really a bit was I thought that
was kind of fine thing yeah she provides
the papers as it is laminated to me yeah
yeah kind of what I'm telling them have
been traumatic to see I think oh yeah
I'm sure if you were there yeah but I
think as Tom mentioned over time they
said that they establish communication
with a whole host of spirits which they
called the spirit team which I thought
was kind of cute yeah and these members
of the spirit team would tell them
various things and they and now okay
although it was claimed that some of the
voices of the spirit team would come out
of thin air or come out of the corners
nothing like that in general I think
most of the voices of the spirit team
came through the mediums yes like this
is it was just them speaking in other
voices Sandra with other personalities
and things like that and there's
recording to the voices and it does
like an Edwardian woman from a long time
ago talking yeah I remember what the
name of that spirit was supposed to be
mrs. Bradshaw
mrs. bridge mrs. Bradshaw would give you
whole lectures about what it was like on
the other side and what the universe was
really like and what life was for oh
hold on there's another spirit that's
coming through me she wants to talk and
then it's kind of stuff is it
she was very posh miss yeah kind of cool
I think she was kind of and have kind of
ended up being their favorite one
because it said that after all of this
time that they were doing these
experiments you know they kind of you
know all the spirit team kind of became
part of their family and yes like that
you know you could add some questions
read an actor yeah and you know they had
all different ones they had one name
Patrick McKenna who was an Irish priest
they had one name Rajee who was from
India yeah Emily Bradshaw and a bit like
a school mistress they said and they
also said that there was another group
of spirits that were like on a higher
plane that would sometimes communicate
through the lower spirits that were
talked through the spirit team so we
have like three layers of spirits going
on here elementals and angelic beings
right right so now it should be noted to
that and actually this kind of ties in
now one of the spirits that supposedly
contacted them was Thomas Edison yeah
he kept instructions in matter good now
before we get into that let me say this
is one of the weirdest manifestations of
all the skull experiment kind of seances
what they would do now the first thing
they started doing and I get that one of
the spirit teams told them to do this or
so they claimed they would bring in a
camera and they would sit it in the
middle of the table where they were
having their say on now the room where
they're having the cellar where there
has a camera just a roll of film no it
was first at first it was a camera okay
okay now the the room where they were
holding these séances which they
affectionately termed the
goal hole was almost pitch-black yeah no
light sources no windows no nothing so
it was really really dark in there but
they took those putting a camera in all
the room now
some like saundra claimants of the other
mediums claimed that in the darkness
they would hear the camera lifting up
off the table and kind of wishing around
over their heads and they wish hear the
shutter clicking right now when they
would later develop the film there was
all this weird [__] on it like there
were like there were pictures that look
like colored bubbles there were pictures
that looked like kind of impressionistic
sort of designs with like human faces
and then yeah I think there was one that
looked like pyramids there was one that
looked like I think it was st. Peter's
Cathedral in London during the Blitz
yeah you know things like that so like
all these pictures would mysteriously
appear yeah I want to strange things
about it this some of this some of those
photos that were that would be produced
would be you know I hate to say it much
stock photos well yeah that picture of
st. Peter's Cathedral sure was and I
think one of the photos they produced
was actually sir Arthur Conan Doyle
because I did I seen that picture that
doesn't every book about him right so
you know that's a little fishy that
these pictures that appeared now after a
while the spirit team evidently told
them that they didn't need the camera
anymore they just needed to bring some
film in and they would put things on the
film right and they claimed that they
would bring in film they wouldn't even
take it out of the package or anything
like that and then later when they
developed it there would be all the [__]
on it now after a while it wasn't just
pictures now it was like writing it was
like writing online drawings and it was
in all different languages I think there
was one there was there was some poems
in German there was some in Sanskrit I
think one there's are some in Latin yeah
there was some Greek one there was a
Greek one so there was stuff that were
there were turbans home yeah they were
German there were some that were like
cryptograms there were like little
symbols that they all like a high weird
yeah and like some of them they figured
out but they didn't I don't think they
ever told us what they said but they
said they figured about something that
didn't figure out and going back to what
I was saying about Thomas Edison one of
these films that they developed it had
this writing on it and then it had a
little diagram on a little of a little
doohickey know how to build some I've
had to build something called a
germanium something or other yeah and it
was I yeah and it was supposed to help
them like communicate with the spirits
better and it was signed tes yes and
when they investigated they found that
the little signature matched Kate TAS
right
it matched Thomas Edison ounces what the
[__] am I saying adds on Oh Thomas Alva
sta E
yes Thomas Alva Edison Jesus Christ I
don't know what to do so um so yeah so
apparently the signatures match so
Thomas Edison was telling them how to
build a little doohickey - you know
facilitator you talk to them by their
given some techno technology special
spirit technology right and sometimes
there were um like I said that you know
on a side note Thomas Edison was trying
to talk to the dead so was Marconi he
was yeah and if test of trying to talk
to the dead actually brought forth ideas
like radio the idea can't grow and I
believe x-ray technology originally had
something to do with trying to catch
goats on film yeah you might be right
about that I said I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure that that Edison was kind of
into the Spiritualist yeah he was
experience also anyway they were trying
to talk to the dead even back in the day
yeah well you know it caused technology
as weird technology is magic that works
yes yes sure
so like I said these happened over a
really long period of time now all of
the people the mediums that were there
all of the Society for psychical
research people that were there some
other kind of well-known scientists like
Rupert Sheldrake the biochemist
biochemist or something like that he was
there he had some wacky ideas but you
know I like Sheldrake though
he seemed trying to legit most vicious
kind of legit even though he does have
way kind of open minded you know he
doesn't say he knows that you know such
as such as true just like maybe or maybe
we should consider this you know now
some of stuff that she'll drink believes
or at least considered I think is a
little wacky like the concept that we
know how human eye works we know how
eyes work yeah life goes into it like a
lens and then there's rods and cones in
the back of it and an image is formed in
your mind for a while they're using and
well maybe something's coming out of the
eyeball that's right not as that guy
yeah yeah and making things real which
is you have an alternate explanation for
vision but I think we safely say that no
yeah that's how it all works he does
also do a lot of investigation into
telepathic communication between animals
and humans yeah which is actually yes
not as crazy as it sounds evidence it
was suggested that dogs know when the
owners coming back home there's no where
they could hear you know yeah I mean you
just tell it to lepa see between people
to you know like that was what I
remembered most because I wouldn't have
a fight because I was always trying to
establish psychic communication with our
kitty cats she knows what I'm saying
yeah she knows and I'm thinking I were
to see back anyway so he was one of the
ones that was there and so they all said
I mean they all seemed to be believing
that they saw they said they saw figures
they said they saw faces disembodied
food disembodied hands that touch them
yeah when we were thinking about the
disembodied faces if they were they
would see a hazy face that could talk
and you move and talk at the same time
right floating around in the room no I
didn't say whether or not it was an
image on the wall yes we can get to that
later or just yeah just see an image
there was also some apparent like
poltergeist activity you know the
standard table rising odd right and
everybody I'm spinning yes that's what I
was going to say they have luminous
crystals around the outer rim
of the table I guess like glued on the
outside and they said that there they
run glue they were suspected oh they
were just out there okay yeah we went
send it when it was fun they didn't fly
off right and they said they saw this
but like I said it should be noted that
every single one of these dances took
place in the dark complete darkness it
was pretty much complete darkness no
they said complete darkness yeah other
than any radiant light that would come
up with something that was glowing right
now when the SPR dudes investigated and
like I said this is why I kind of
hesitate to call as an experiment
because yes they did try to establish
some kind of rudimentary controls but
pretty much the extent of that was they
made the mediums will they actually the
medium he said the medium suggested no
he will wear luminous wristbands that
are fastened with Velcro so you can see
where our hands are at all times so you
know we're not moving our hands right
and that was pretty much the only
control that was established yeah and
that was the medium suggestion and right
then so you know I don't know and let's
we're at the halfway point so let's take
a break and after we come back from the
break I kind of want to break down what
the problem what's the problem car with
a lot of these experiments lot of
problems with this yeah you know at the
beginning I just kind of wanted to say
what they said they saw and why they
were all excited that I also want to
talk a little bit about that documentary
the famous documentary like the social
one about that yeah you know when I
first found this case I mentioned in a
book sometime to 90s and then I saw that
documentary a long time ago the one that
we re watched again yeah and at the time
I was like wow this is a really
extraordinary case jeez there must be
something to this what he claimed him
that was younger than you know and now
that I look at it now and then read some
of the critical analysis of this above
course and really when you hear the
story of the school experiments in more
detail there are huge problems with this
yeah Daniel and honestly I didn't know
like a huge amount about this until
recently like I had heard of it and I
had heard of how it was this big like
earth-shaking yeah you know series of
experiments and it's pretty honest and
that all this and you know this really
and it's gonna happen and stuff like
that but then when I started looking
into it and really detail what actually
have an even like I said seeing the kind
of documentary that was produced about
it I'm like it's really not all that
compelling I have to say and well that's
compelling but not in quite in the
direction I think that they wanted it to
go yeah that's a way of putting it ok so
let's take a break and we will be back
in just a few minutes ladies and
gentlemen Radek Entertainment Network
presents the mentor is the greatest
manager of all time becoming superstar
good great
kill mean I'm not against each other
camera no right up front may be used to
either a like a local some carry Emma -
to me I'm tracking entertainment network
subculture courses in clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets comm set subculture
corsets comm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets comm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 watch out there's
a new killer taking over kitchens around
the world
thrills chills mad cooking skills it
cooks a weekly podcast coming with
recipe tips food finds seasonal specials
and guests galore
hosted by horror author amber Fallon hey
that's me
a foodie was over 20 years experience
cooking baking and generally making a
nuisance of herself you watch the Food
Network you've read cookbooks but
nothing can prepare you for it Cook's
coming to a device near you
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
talk pen to paper and conclude at the
end of the day that this house is
variable tortured and will continue to
be on to prevail on champion okay the
school experiment yes big problem now
here's the thing let's talk a little bit
about the documentary and if you want to
watch the documentary it's called the
afterlife experiment yeah or the
afterlife what the [__] is a call
afterlife something all of you guys have
your life uncovered yeah you can see it
: you guys see it for goal experience
you can see it for free on you it's all
over YouTube UFO TV has it there's a
link to it from the scope official role
or ever going to watch it just yeah get
it you'll get a job you're going to
giggle out of it yeah now here like I
said if you are already inclined to
believe it then I can see why the
documentary might be like might confirm
your belief the does the documentary is
a mishmash of a bunch of [__] together
most of it doesn't have anything as
vehicle that's the first criticism of
the documentary is that yeah it's called
the afterlife whatever its but it's
supposed to be about the skull
experiment the problem is the actual
skull experiments were not videotaped
the videotape footage you see in the
documentary is a [__] all day on its
mouth group of originally with the same
medium Noga that took place in 2008 so
those are not skull experiments the
video that you're seeing there are
snippets of audio because audio was
permitted at the skull experiment but
not video so there is no video footage
there are some photographs but not very
many
another thing is that the documentary is
really not it's not very focused there's
a large chunk of it taken up with
there's a guy in Italy named by his
name's Bochy right and survived
he's doing the old Marconi thing yeah
where he he claims to be able to talk to
dead people through the radio radio yeah
and all these people come and they talk
people and it's all very heartwarming
and everything like that but you know
that doesn't really have anything to do
with the skull experiment now this
medium role of it this mediums did visit
that guy's but not until after the
school experiment ago but I don't
understand how you can have some old guy
with an hand antique radio okay talking
to the dead and receiving messages from
the dead and he's going oh by the way
there's no one in this area with the
transmitter yeah I don't think they
could rule that out
yeah there's no way that there's a
transmitter in this area that somebody
tell me what a transmitter talking to
the radii seems like a very easy thing
yeah and they're evidently seeing and
hearing what's going on in the so-called
seance room and responding to the
questions yeah there's a buck the place
is bugged yeah you know what's like I
said again to be able to do so but so it
seems like a large part of the
documentary is taken up with that
there's also a lot of useless footage of
kind of person on the street like you
know they go around angling to go what
do you think about the afterlife you
think there is one it's like this their
opinions or not about it no their
opinions don't mean [__] and then there
and the way it's edited in the sound
effects in the background you know they
kind of pushing you in the direction hey
because this person random person on the
street believes in an afterlife it's
true yeah that's like I cannot stand
like documentaries that try to bolster
their case by just asking random people
what their opinion is I'm like who
[__] cares what their opinion is
there doesn't matter it doesn't make
things any less true or fault the whole
thing asking a random person with their
opinion is the whole purpose of the
so-called goal experiments was to prove
the existence of life after death right
okay and that's not happening in this
program and it didn't happen in this
goal experiment yeah but like I said the
documentary not compelling oh oh and
they also took up a large chunk of time
with this poor woman and I feel bad for
her yeah his son who died in a boat
accident and she claims that she can
talk to him through this little recorder
and I want the woman as the woman
clearly unhinged and it's very sad and
you know you would be sad if your son
dad that was sauce room but you know I
just I don't like the whole kind of
exploitative and like I said that didn't
have anything to do with the school
experiment either it seems the whole
documentary seemed very thin like
because they don't have much footage of
it they reuse the same footage they we
use the same shots over no really the
whole the whole documentary is talking
about the Skjold experiments but not
showing you this goal experiment and
avoiding most of the skull experience
yeah because like they said they had no
video footage yeah of the skull
experiment I don't mention anything
outside of their conclusion in other
words they don't present any of the
problems at the school yeah like I think
they have one token skeptic on there
who's on screen for maybe three minutes
right through the whole thing same thing
no I don't think so but then they have
like all these other people going Oh
scientists or materialists and they
don't believe yeah but the thing is okay
let's get down to the nitty-gritty let's
get down to the problem and little
experiment was not an experiment it was
a demonstration basically and the reason
why it was not an experiment because
there were no control right the two
major problems are this they would only
do the seances at the hot at the home of
the people of the voice of the voice I
think there were a couple done other
places but that was the main that was
amazing and when they did them somewhere
else
the results were varied a quote unquote
variable variable according to another
according to its own report they could
not produce the same phenomenon in other
locations and they were going to courts
are going to give excuses why and here's
the second problem they would hope that
the the biggest claim that in other
words is the strongest piece of evidence
that the case has is this strange
anomaly about film images images being
produced on film well it's inside of a
locked box and bit untouched by people
all right developed by the investigators
right boom which seems pretty airtight
that sounds good
the problem is that's always their box
and they could never use someone else's
box the box upon further examination
could be even though it would lock could
be easily opened at the hinges without
the Hat without the without disengaging
without disengaging the lock Oh wasn't
the hinges
there was a half yeah you could get into
the box and it should be noted that this
fact was pointed out in the school
report by that scientist Montague keen
yeah who was one of the SPR guys yes who
was at a lot of the sessions and who in
the documentary he's dead now
unfortunately but concealing ours man
but it was in the documentary he seemed
all gung-ho about this whole experiment
but he wrote himself that this spot
provided by the medium yeah was taken to
the University of Nottingham and it was
found that it could be easily opened
without disengaging the padlock yeah now
the Foy's would say well everyone
sitting at the table had glowing
armbands on we know nobody reached
across the table to open the box and
change switch to film but the thing is
this is happening in a dark room this
goal all goes all the way back to the
early nineteen hundred's late
18-hundreds where you're having a
traditional seance in a blackened room
all right with assistants wearing black
clothes black igloo leotards that come
out of an adjoining room or from out
from underneath secret compartments and
couches and in furniture they come out
and they do all this stuff just like in
a stage act yeah that's a magic trick
and the glowing balls LED lights on the
ends of wires or laser or laser pointers
that touch crystals and illuminate them
now this whole thing about the faces and
the moving images easily explained by
pinholes what do we call that like a
pinhole camera and whole cameras and
explain them how a pinhole camera can
work well basically it's just I mean
when you make a pinhole camera I made
one of ourselves in school but you're
just making a box and you're making it
so light can come in but it's only
coming out the other end
little tiny yes no that and it yeah and
it casts an image it's upside down
upside down and you can you know project
this image on a film where you can
project it under a wall or whatever it's
not a clear image obviously right
because it's very crude so what you can
do and there was an adjoining room to
that basis to that base which was only
checked one one at the beginning a
series and reportedly was not ever
checked again right what you can do is
you can have somebody in an adjoining
room or you can have somebody hidden in
a piece of furniture that's totally
light tight notes all about where only
light can exit but it has a light source
inside there so you have a little more a
litt compartment with a person who is
probably upside down okay because he's
looking through a small really you know
upside down and it casts an image out
through a pinhole and then you have an
assistant all on a black leotard with a
small handheld mirror capturing that
image and then reflecting it into the
room and he can he can put it anywhere
inside that room with using a small
handheld mirror there's a bunch of
little magic tricks that you can do this
to do the phenomenon it's reported
nothing in number phenomena was
inexplicable yeah look at and like I
said even even the kind of stuff like
Rupert Sheldrake and some of the other
people that said they saw a disembodied
hand like I said that would also be easy
to move like I said someone with a black
suit they can have a blob on and they
have luminous paint on their hand they
can take the glove off at some point and
um see you know you would see the hand
and that's it if you have two or three
hidden assistants in black leotard some
of them in the room some of them outside
the room it's totally core choreographed
just like a stage magic show all right
you can produce a lot of strange
phenomena that is impressive to people
who don't know what they're seeing and
there won't be any evidence of trickery
or deception and we should note that
there was never found to be any evidence
of broader trickery right that doesn't
mean there wasn't any and that doesn't
mean it's real I don't like I said I
don't want to cast aspersions on the
boys you know they seem like nice old
people and stuff like that I don't want
to come out and say
yeah they were defrauding people or yeah
they were doing all these tricks however
because of the way the school
experiments were conducted there is no
way to rule that out because honestly
all of the phenomena that's produced
that was produced could have been faked
yeah look at it this way and it wouldn't
have been difficult to fake them these
claims are so earth-shattering is so
great and and the evidence if it were so
great science the scientific community
would be all over this
yeah they weren't yes they weren't
because they saw through it because of
the lack of the controls yeah it's in
the same ways it's the same with a say
like Penn & Teller or David Blaine David
Blaine does some awesome magic tricks
there's no evidence there's no
suggestion of deception really in what
you're seeing if you're gonna be just
sitting there in your chair or your
watching the trick there's no evidence
of deception but it's a deception
everybody knows it's a deception that's
why you don't have scientists going to
David Blaine trying to figure out how to
violating you know the laws of others
right knows it's a trick we do the same
thing even though you can't figure out
how he did it it's bill ania it's still
a trick and in a darkened room with a
team of basically magician you know you
can produce some awesome phenomena
that's uh compelling okay I'm going to
who's sitting there at a table yeah all
right now there's a lot of stuff they
would not allow they would not allow
night-vision cameras no infrared no
infrared so that right there that's the
red that's a red flag they're going to
come up with some kind of spiritualist
response well that those infrared
radiation breaks down the spirits
ability to move things and what they
really mean is is that you'll see guys
in black leotards running around the
room lighting the dark yeah I should
know too that there was a scene in the
documentary because I forgot to mention
this of one of the newer seances and
they were all very excited that these
flower petals had quote-unquote awkward
and into the room yeah what's weird
about that one
this particular science was not even
conducted under the very last controls
of the school experiment - I find it
interesting that the cameraman somehow
knew to film everyone's feet all of a
sudden yes when the rose petals were
falling yeah they shot up yeah before
they were filming the table like all the
people's faces yeah you know so it
seemed a little fishy I'm like Oh
suddenly you just decided to film
everyone's feet and like flower petals
happen to fall okay I'm not buying it
now here's another thing this is why it
doesn't fruit it doesn't prove the
existence of the app of the afterlife
which was that was the whole point of
the school experiment all you have to do
is listen to Robin Boyd on maybe one of
his podcast yeah we listened to one
yesterday about a two-hour interview
you'll find out that mr. Freud believes
in everything he believes in everything
at the same time he believes in ghosts
angels demons life after death
aliens um what else elemental spirits
jinn okay well his claim is is that
these are voices of dead people but if
you also believe in jinn and demons and
things like that what's to say that
these are not the voices of dead people
but these are jinn okay right
impersonating dead people or maybe
psychic parasites so still it wouldn't
be evidence you have to prove that dead
people that are talk of you well and not
not just elemental spirits claiming to
be dead people so you know there's very
problematic and it should be noted too
that even if the phenomena the people
saw at this at the school experiment
were genuine yeah that would not prove
afterlife no because those same things
if they were genuinely paranormal could
have been produced by psychokinesis for
example his psychic powers or something
like that of the living people that were
there exactly so like I said again does
approve existence of life after death
which is what they sought out to prove
right
um I'd also like I think I forgot to
mention this when we were talking about
what they saw at the thing was it
remember the thing about the crystal
yeah
the crystal would light up on other
better data types occur yeah now
evidently what happened I forgot to
mention this earlier one of the things
that they said they saw and some of the
Society for psychical research science
guys said they thought us they had a
little like a little crystal course or
whatever it was and they said they saw
it float up and then it came back down
and it landed in a little glass dish and
the ghost told them to touch it and they
touched it and it was normal and solid
and then they said okay now touch it
again and they touch it again now you
could still see the crystal just like
before but now their fingers just went
through it like it is not like it had no
material substance and the ghost the
spirit team claimed that this is what
they were trying to this is how they
were trying to demonstrate you know what
spiritual energy would look like you can
still see it it looks normal but it's
like in material right it's like the
spirit of the crystal right yes but it
should be noted even though that you
know people said that they saw this and
they said they touched him then they
couldn't touch it witness testimony is
subjective yeah there's no video of it
it was down inside of a glass dish oh
yeah some sort I suspect it was some
kind of a reflection yeah it may have
been well or another possibility nothing
to crime more likely because this wasn't
videotaped you're just dealing with
witness testimony it that may have never
happened at all they just claims that
that happened yeah like I said there's
no way of proving that that's a this is
why witness testimony that's like the
worst it's the worst aspect of any kind
of paranormal stuff it's because
everyone's experience is a subjective I
have no problem Dennis and they have no
problem presenting witness testimony but
you can't claim that to be proved
it's just testimony yes just like in a
court of law witness testimony is not
evidence it's just testimony yeah
evidence is physical yeah all right
and that's and
and proof can only come from evidence
yes because there are so many things I
mean that person could be lying they
could be mistaken they could have been
seeing run you know that you know there
could have been fraud and they thought
it was real you know what I mean it's
right we're not necessarily saying that
they were just making it up maybe they
did see that but maybe that thing was
produced in a way that yeah that they
weren't expecting or maybe it was a
trick and they fell for it or something
like that and like I said the problem
with the school experiment of why it's
you know not nearly as big a deal as a
lot of people in the paranormal
community think it is is because there's
just no way of knowing oh my god it
could be real I don't actually think
it's a big deal in the paranormal
community I think it's more of a big
deal in the spiritualist community yeah
it was all subsets of the paranormal
Indian age type thing sure and really
when you look at the when you look at
the the overall pattern of the entire
school experiment that's that's 19th
century spiritualism this isn't a
traditional seance with a couple of
high-tech new high-tech tricks but
mostly the same kind of trick same thing
just as a higher tech spin on it yeah I
mean and we talked a little bit about
this on our Houdini in the spiritualist
show you know all the mediums back panel
with spiritualist mediums they employed
like a pretty standard bag of tricks for
doing these various manifestations like
I said they would have accomplices they
would have you know ten whole cameras
now at nowadays you know they can use
laser pointers and inva and limit paint
various other things but it's really no
I mean I didn't see anything in the
skull experiment that couldn't that was
any different than what the
manifestation back then other than the
film thing right but I've seen magicians
do that type of [__] all you have to do
is do three things and no and it would
totally foil the entire school
experiment one take this take a whole
group the whole all your stance is that
you know all getting all your mediums
and all people the guess to the sale and
you move that to a neutral area like a
warehouse where no one knows ahead of
time I want to
as ahead of time then you introduce a
box a control box in other words a box
that actually locks and everybody agrees
that there's no way to get into it you
put that on a table and three put it put
a camera an IR camera
there'd be no phenomena yeah well and it
should be noted that Richard Wiseman he
submitted his own you know lights lights
proof envelopes for some of the film I
wonder when they put the film in there
instead of their special lock box yeah
nothing nothing half turned up on it now
turned up on it there's another thing
that's quite fishy he stopped the
experiment yeah amazing idea in 1998
wouldn't continue anymore and what's the
reason tell Jenny the reason reportedly
is that he had opened an
interdimensional doorway I believe yes
in order to facilitate kind of this
communication or whatever it was they
were trying to do and apparently
experimenters were coming from the
future and various other ghosts and
spirits were coming hi travelers yes and
telling him that his interdimensional
doorway was messing up the space-time
continuum and it needed to be closed yes
and this was not mentioned in any
documentary I just found it on like a
parent on his right and evident like I
said I don't know that's true but it was
reported on that that's good any truth
that does that and after listening to
him for a couple hours yesterday I'm
like yeah that's not bad I just like him
that sounds like I don't think you said
that's the same kind of thing that a
1800s yeah because you can't be kid
would prove that you can't realize that
basically it's equivalent to saying well
God has told me to stop it yeah yeah I
don't like the angel said stop yeah and
you know of course you know they're
stopping because they know that people
are on to them and it's only a matter of
time before the whole thing or they've
got some bad it was good now I think
there was some monetary motive to well
they do have a book the case was
monetized
put it that way they they were selling a
book and what else well they were
selling the documentary that you can see
on YouTube they also have a 2 DVD set of
I believe it's the same documentary but
it's catalyzed extra footage and stuff
like that so yeah you gotta pay for that
if you want to see it they have the 300
page school report which I believe is 15
pounds which aramis that is an American
currency today but you know you can buy
that and they have a whole book about it
they're actually pretty good at keeping
information about it like what actually
happened
you know there's summaries of it
everywhere but I think they want you to
buy the book there's not you know
there's a little snippets of audio
that's about it yeah but I don't really
think the book was the moneymaker
yeah ask me what I think was going on is
that the entire school experiment was an
advertisement yeah we're a seance
service yeah
because they could hold séances in the
house yeah so if you want to say I'm
done to talk to a dead loved one who are
you going to go to well somebody who has
this yeah Little Dipper baby yes it's
super famous sure No
so they were probably charging people
you know admission into seances outside
the school experiment yeah we don't know
that were just about probably worse
because that would be a decent way to
make a few bucks it's just like oh your
son died well you know who we are
come on in yeah we can double we'll go
talk to them yeah gonna cost you 400
bucks yeah that I guarantee that's what
was all about I gotta say that like the
more the more we talked about this case
and stuff like that because I as much as
I think like seances are fake and [__]
like that
I love the whole like aesthetic of them
especially the old Victorian ones all
the ectoplasm the glowing [__] that's so
awesome yeah we should actually have our
own self service see that's what I
wanted to do I said okay you know how
you know how people have like a murder
mystery dinner theater and submit that
okay you should do one like that but
it's like this seance experience yes you
could have like a Victorian parlor yet
with all the candles and [__] you let
everybody know it's a magic trick
yeah you can't sit don't tell people
it's real none of that sucks don't do
that but you know if they know they're
like you're going to get the experience
of a sound you
real is just like a magic show right and
you'll have like all these and you know
and feel like a little glowing horn to
be flying around I'd be [__] awesome
yeah we rehearse it and train our
friends how to do it what's it listen
hey would you guys contribute to a
chapter in our life because if somebody
else did that I would be all over that
[__] I would be I would go every week
you have to like change the show up
every now and then yeah and you'd like
personalize it to you if you had to be
that was good at like cold reading or
that kind of candidate from the house
and start tearing apart the house to
have secret rooms and stuff you could go
in and out of place or couches that came
apart
oh man getting out of a couch and you
need near you need basically told
darkness yeah well if I had got it I'm
just to borrow a phrase from the
god-awful movies podcast if I had crazy
billionaire money yeah I was just hurt
to take on six PS I would say oh another
thing I wanted to mention to you about
the [__] seance isn't about how it
wasn't anything impressive was I'm going
to talk about the AB horse yeah good if
you'll notice everything that was
aborted and there's like pictures of it
online it was like little [__] was like
a pocketknife I would've owned that it
was a necklace stuff like that I said
okay now if you really want to impress
me with a seance
let's see you [__] a port an SUV or a
live giraffe yeah
let's see how that you know they'll be
but the Copperfield could do that on
camera that's true all right but here's
the thing after 10 o'clock we're just
going to call it like we see it not all
this paranormal stuff is true not all of
it not it it can't all be true yeah but
I think some of it is and some of it is
a mixture of true and false but you know
because I've seen paranormal stuff
though Jenny you know good classic
poltergeist and an OBE and I had an NDE
but a lot of that subjective yeah we
thing that was objective which me and my
family witness classic poltergeist
phenomena yeah so but when it comes to
things like
seance uh no and also I was almost side
with Houdini
yeah well Chris you I have some that I
was and I have to say like on this one
too it seems like it later they tried to
like tie it in with other stuff like
like one of the images that they
obtained
look like a cartoon of a blue alien face
yeah now they're saying you know some of
them are aliens or they're
interdimensional beings or what nothing
that's the kind of scoop in some of the
UFO cult Stefan I mean they're just
widening their market why do you know
I'm like I said I don't want to be a
dick they seem like nice people and I
guess they're still alive I don't know
but you know they seem like nice people
do I think they were perpetrating a
fraud probably I'm not going to say that
but because there were no controls in
place because they weren't really
investigated all that stringently
there's no way of knowing so any
conclusions they came to are useless
right that's all I'm saying if they were
the real deal then they need to redo the
experiment with real control it controls
real controls on it like you said has to
take place somewhere other than their
house and of course that's not going to
happen everybody it should be filmed in
for everything and everything should be
brought to them they should not be
allowed to say oh we're going to make
limits armbands and put them on oh we're
going to bring a box about the film in
but of course that's not going to happen
but no hi I'm travelers from the future
told them that they were going to rip
apart the space-time continuum if they
can so they can't do it any handy
efficient so he's protecting us now well
I appreciate that thank you pretty sure
yeah anyway okay so we're coming to the
end of the show I hope you enjoyed that
again rail I don't think that was his
rambling as they usually are though know
if you like the seance topic we also did
one a couple weeks back on Houdini and
his debunking of spiritualist so I'll
put a link there if you want to read
that yeah on the YouTube show I would
only mention the shirt know the answer
we got shirts if you want to go to
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock they're very
cool we have some ourselves yeah and we
have a really short coming yeah I'm
going to do a curly shirt next actually
because we did curly a couple weeks ago
yeah and you know and also another
shout-out to your project entertainment
network on which our audio version is
hosted they have a patreon if you want
to go give them some money and also if
you want to like us on Facebook or
follow us on Twitter where it's 13
o'clock podcast and that's probably
about it right I mean all the usual [__]
I say yeah and in that you should end
this one
not a song what I found me what music on
I know well that was first time I ever
did that just because it was cool you
need to get the end of it
well now I have to think of it stay on
world my thoughts oh my god
okay I'm making my life Oh Ouija board
oh there you go from Boris goddammit
alright alright I'm gonna put that at
the end look honest assessment okay so
uh see you guys next Tuesday
bye what she was I read you balls balls
would you work for me
I
[Music]
good
soon
[Music]